[Musique]
le
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition
des matins du sénat poursuivre
aujourd'hui l'audition de marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état aux droits
des femmes elle était auditionné la
semaine dernière par la délégation aux
droits des femmes justement la première
audition de la sorte depuis 2010 est a
rappelé la présidente annick billon la
ministre a pu faire un premier temps un
premier bilan de la loi sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles une loi
votée l an dernier elle a également pu
défendre son budget pour 2020 un budget
qui vous allez le voir interroge à la
fois les sénatrices les sénateurs mais
aussi les associations allée direction à
la salle rené coty poursuivre cette
audition sur tout juste un frère d'abord
un mot si vous me permettez un peu
familièrement pour vous souhaiter un
joyeux anniversaire pour ce vingtième
anniversaire de la délégation aux droits
des femmes du sénat la présidente mme
expliqué l instant que vous avez célébré
par un temps de travail de mobilisation
ce vingtième anniversaire
comme vous savez l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est la grande
cause du quinquennat du président la
république et cette grande cause elle
nous permet de mener un combat culturel
pour abaisser le seuil de tolérance de
toute la société
face aux inégalités entre les femmes et
les hommes et particulièrement aux
violences sexistes et sexuelles
je vais m'attacher à répondre aux
questions vous avez soulevé madame la
présidente en tâchant de ne pas être
trop longue car je crois que nous avons
un temps imparti
bref et je ne sais pas si certains ou
certaines d'entre vous doivent retourner
en séance par ailleurs toutefois je vais
essayer d'être quand même plus longue
que gérald darmanin mon collègue qui
tout à l'heure à projets de répondre par
oui ou par non aux questions sur le
budget je vais tenter de détailler un
petit peu davantage d'abord sur ce qui
concerne le grenelle des violences
conjugales je voudrais remercier
l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui se sont mobilisés parce
que nous avons l'avons dit dès le départ
ce grenelle des violences conjugales il
ne peut produire des effets que si il y
à une mobilisation générale et je sais
que plusieurs d'entre vous vous même la
présidente mais également des sénatrices
et des sénateurs se sont mobilisés à la
fois ici dans un travail de réflexion
d'un long travail législatif mais aussi
dans le travail partenarial et en
circonscription avec les actrices et les
acteurs et les élus avec lesquels vous
travaillez tous les jours en france
contre les violences conjugales donc
véritablement je vous
vous remercier pour cela parce que je
crois que c'est grâce à cette
mobilisation collective autour du
grenelle des violences conjugales que
nous avons pu avoir de premiers chiffres
uniquement sur la question de 39 19
mais elle est importante vous le savez
peut-être le mardi 3 septembre
donc le mardi 3 9 19 le numéro du 39 19
enregistrée 1661 appel et depuis il y a
toujours en moyenne plus de 600 appels
par jour au lieu de 200 en moyenne
environ
habituellement c'est une augmentation en
nombre considérable est derrière cette
augmentation cela signifie qu'il ya
davantage de femmes qui sont accompagnés
orienté prise en charge par le 39 19
suites à cette mobilisation en 2017
c'est 8 à 9% de la population qui
connaît le numéro du 39 19
et maintenant après grenelle des
violences conjugales c'est 59 % de la
population française qui connaît le 39
19 d'après les derniers chiffres que
nous avons dont nous disposons qui ont
été étudiées juste après le lancement du
grenelle des violences conjugales
nous allons poursuivre par une deuxième
salve d'études après le 25 novembre pour
voir si ce chiffre reste au parce qu'on
sait qu'il peut rester au dans les
esprits juste après une campagne de
communication mais redescendre par la
suite et nous notre volonté c'est qu'il
reste aux parce que ça veut dire que sur
dix personnes à qui s'adresse une femme
victime de violences conjugales il y en
a six désormais qui peuvent lui indiquer
ce numéro du 39 19
et cette hausse de la notoriété du 39 19
et des appels passés au 39 19 donc cette
hausse des femmes prises en charge
elle a été permise grâce à la
mobilisation collective de toute la
société des médias mais aussi des élus
qui se sont relayés pour faire en sorte
de passer ses messages et donc très
sincèrement vous remercier pour cela
ce grenelle des violences conjugales
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente il
n'est pas terminée nous sommes à une
pro pas tout à fait encore à une
première étape onze groupes de travail
ont été décidées dans le cadre de la
cession du grenelle des violences
conjugales à matignon et ses onze
groupes de travail ils sont constitués
d'experte et d'experts dans des
thématiques données qui se réunissent
régulièrement et qui auditionne à leur
tour des personnes engagées sur ces
sujets là pour établir d'abord un
diagnostic précis de la situation
actuelle champ par champ mais surtout
établir des propositions
les thèmes de ces groupes de travail ce
sont les violences intrafamiliales
l'éducation la santé le monde du travail
l'outre-mer j'y reviendrai la question
du handicap est votre rapport sera bien
sûr très éclairant a à cet égard
l'accueil en commissariats et
gendarmeries l'hébergement la justice
les violences psychologiques et
l'emprise et les violences économiques
en ce qui concerne le groupe de travail
sur l'outre-mer nous avons décidé de
décliner en plusieurs étapes il ya donc
un groupe de travail spécifique piloté
par le ministère des autres maires sous
l'autorité de ma collègue annick
girardin
mais en plus de ce groupe de travail
outre-mer nous organiserons un grenelle
outre-mer spécifique qui aura lieu à la
réunion dans les prochaines semaines et
qui permettra de mobiliser l'ensemble
des acteurs et des actrices autour de
ces thématiques précises
nous savons qu'il ya un enjeu très fort
en outre-mer je ne vais pas la prendre
évidemment aux élus d'outre-mer
le rapport du seco qui était paru
environ trois ans qui pointait
précisément les spécificités de ce à
quoi nous faisons face en outre mer sont
très éclairante à cet égard notamment en
ce qui concerne le 39 19
on a une question de développement sur
l'ensemble du territoire y compris en
outre mer
mais pas uniquement été groupe de
travail ils vont pouvoir le 29 octobre
proposait les résultats de leurs travaux
et de leurs propositions et j'ai
souhaité que ce soit fait de manière
publique c'est à dire ce sera pas une
remise ni à moi même ni au premier
ministre ce sera une restitution
publique de leurs propositions afin que
chacune et chacun puisse venir s'en
emparer et bien évidemment les
parlementaires au premier chef
que les parlementaires puissent être là
et s'en empare et si elle est il
souhaite porter ses propositions
donc j'espère mesdames les sénatrices et
monsieur le sénateur vous voir à cette
occasion le 29 octobre autour des
responsables de chaque groupe de travail
ce grenelle des violences conjugales
je tiens quand même à rappeler qu'ils
marquent une mobilisation sans précédent
lancée par le premier ministre edouard
philippe à matignon avec 15 membres de
son gouvernement
engagés dans ces groupes de travail
directement et dans la mobilisation
je crois que nous avons énormément à
faire collectivement puisqu'on voit que
malgré les efforts des gouvernements
successifs incluant le nôtre depuis des
années le nombre des féministes ne
baisse pas quelles que soient les
politiques publiques qui sont mises en
oeuvre elles n'ont jamais permis de
faire drastiquement largement baisser le
nombre de féministes qui d'après les
décomptes dont nous disposons reste
entre 120 et 150 années après années
selon les différentes manières de les
compter à ce sujet et simplement pour
être clair et partagé un même niveau
d'information je voudrais éclaircir
peut-être à éclaircir mais précise et
des propos qui ont été tenus par mon
collègue le ministre de l'intérieur et
que me faire réagir certaines et
certains d'entre vous quand il a dit
qu'il ne pouvait pas que le gouvernement
ne pouvait pas endosser le décompte mené
par les associations en termes de
féminicide je crois que ce décompte
celle est salutaire et il a très
largement contribué à éveiller les
consciences sur l'ampleur du phénomène
des féminicides mais comme vous savez en
tant que gouvernement nous sommes tenus
de respecter les procédures judiciaires
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement publie une fois l'année
écoulée et les décomptes passer un
décompte une étude officielle depuis
plusieurs années maintenant de ces
féministes mais je crois que normand on
peut se réjouir
d'abord que maintenant les féminicides
soit qualifié comme tel ce qui n'était
pas forcément le cas
dix vingt ans en arrière et que peu à
peu grâce au travail militant engagé sur
ce sujet grâce à l'engagement de toutes
et de tous on reconnaît maintenant on
dénombre les féminicides on m'a fait
remarquer récemment qu'il ya peu de
personnes politiques de personnalités
politiques qui utilisent le mot de
féminicide c'est vrai qu'il y en a peu
mais parmi ceux peu de personnalité il
ya le prison la république et le premier
ministre et je crois qu'on peut s'en
réjouir en matière d'éveil des
consciences
ce grenelle des violences conjugales
donc c'est une mobilisation importante
mais je voudrais rappeler qu'il ya
d'autres actions qui avait été menée par
le gouvernement
précédemment mais simplement c'est une
nouvelle méthode une manière d'engager
tout le monde autour de la table de pas
forcément travailler en
si l'eau il ya un an nous avions lancé
un plan de lutte contre les violences
conjugales avec un certain nombre de
mesures qui faisait elle même suite à
cinq plans différents porté par les
gouvernements successifs à cet égard et
pour vous répondre précisément madame la
présidente je voudrais me réjouis lycées
avec vous de la proposition de loi du
député
lr aurélien pradié sur le bracelet anti
rapprochement me réjouir qu'elle était
en discussion à l'assemblée nationale et
arrive bientôt en discussion auprès de
vous c'est une annonce qui a été faite
par le premier ministre edouard philippe
au moment du lancement du grenelle des
violences conjugales qui a été préparé
et travaillée par la garde des sceaux
porter dans l'hémicycle par le député
aurélien pradié et qui a fait l'objet
d'un vote avec un consensus très large
sur la mise en oeuvre de ce bracelet
anti rapprochement qui a fait ses
preuves dans d'autres pays dont je suis
heureuse de constater ce consensus et
cette mise en oeuvre prochaine et de
vous préciser également en réponse à
votre question à madame la présidente
qu'au ministère de la justice va allouer
5 6 millions d'euros pour le lancement
de ces bracelets anti-rapprochement puis
ensuite à 1,8 million d'euros par an
pour soutenir cette disposition et
s'assurer de sa réelle mise en oeuvre le
grenelle des violences conjugales est
donc au coeur de notre actualité à
toutes et à tous mais ce n'est
évidemment pas la totalité de notre
réaction puisque le gouvernement mène
d'autres actions notamment sur la lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
les violences sexuelles le harcèlement
au travail l'excision et c'est le sens
du plan excision nous avions débattu il
y a quelques mois qui a été présenté en
juin dernier
l'émancipation économique des femmes je
reviendrai et la diplomatie féministe
que vous avez évoquées madame la
présidente
peut-être brièvement vous faire part du
premier bilan sur la loi contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
il ya certains sujets sur lesquels nous
n'avons pas encore de bilan et sera donc
présenté en cas d'une mission
d'évaluation qui a été confiée à la
députée alexandra louis qui était
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale de ce
texte
il me semble avoir entendu que le sénat
demande est également de pouvoir avoir
une mission d'évaluation de la loi et
donc ce sera chose faite nous allons
en parler ensemble pour faire en sorte
que ce soit mieux que sa demande est
évidemment légitime
en ce qui concerne la verbalisation du
harcèlement de rue à ce jour ce sont 1
894 infractions qui ont été constatés
depuis la mise en oeuvre de la loi
attention ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y
ait que 894 faits de harcèlement de rue
ou doute rage sexiste dans tout le pays
ça veut dire que ce sont celles qui ont
donné lieu à des infractions constatées
mais c'est quand même un chiffre élevé
parce que je rappelle qu'au moment des
débats sur la verbalisation du
harcèlement de rue certains
commentateurs pouvait mettre en doute la
possibilité est de véritablement
constater ces infractions
en se basant notamment sur les chiffres
de la belgique qui en un an dans n'avait
pu un but puis ont démontré que deux
voix de 894 c'est un chiffre qui montre
tout de même un engagement des forces de
l'ordre on a parmi celles là sans cette
infraction pour voyeurisme six
infractions pour red numérique également
et 9 148 infractions aggravé en raison
de la présence d'un mineur ce qui sont
des faits qui sont des chiffres pardon
qui sont élevés mais bien sûr la mission
d'évaluation de la loi nous permettra
d'en savoir plus nous revient pas sur
les dispositions de la loi nous les
avons largement discutées au moment du
vote de la loi mais je voudrais
remercier peut-être encore les sénateurs
et les sénatrices je veux mener un
travail important pour enrichir cette
fois parce qu'on voit que ça produit des
effets notamment le président de la
commission des lois messieurs philippe
bailly la rapporteure marie mercier et
je crois que nous devrons poursuivre ce
travail ensemble d'évaluation et ensuite
d'évaluation conjointe qui sera remise à
la fois par l'assemblée nationale et par
le sénat pour voir comme où nous étions
engagés
si cette loi est suffisante ou si elle
doit être améliorée et je pense là
notamment à son article 2 sur la
question de la protection des mineurs
face aux violences sexistes et sexuelles
et sur l'efficacité de l'allongement des
délais de prescription pour les crimes
sexuels commis sur mineurs
madame la présidente vous m'avez
interrogé sur la question du budget
voudrais vous indiquer que le dpt sort
demain et vous permettra donc d'avoir
accès directement aux chiffres source et
des ministères divers et variés mais
peut-être vous dire que sur 2020 l'état
consacre 1,116 milliard d'euros pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
361,5 millions de crédits engagés sur la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles parmi lesquels et je vous ai
apporté un soin nombre de documents avec
des détails que je vous laisserai quand
nous quitterons ni en détail il y a deux
ministères particulièrement qui augmente
considérablement leurs engagements
financiers
le ministère des affaires étrangères
avec un certain nombre d'actions de co
développement financés je pense
notamment aux 6 millions d'euros engagés
pour soutenir le fonds de denis mukwege
et prix nobel de la paix de l'année
dernière qui s'engagent contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
notamment en période de guerre le
président de la république a annoncé que
la france était le premier pays à
soutenir ce fonds pour apporter un
soutien et une aide à ces femmes et ça
fait partie des engagements du ministère
des affaires étrangères nous avons
préparé un détail que vous pourrez
trouver dans le dpt mais également
ministère de l'intérieur je peux vous
partagez peut être avec vous quelques
chiffres il ya une mobilisation
importante avec 230 millions d'euros du
ministère de l'intérieur avec notamment
les brigades de protection des familles
avec les correspondants départementaux
et locaux des deux victimes
les références violences conjugales les
recrutements de 73 psychologue par la
police nationale ce qui représente un
engagement de 3 3 millions d'euros des
officiers des correspondants
territoriaux des brigade de prévention
de la délinquance spécifiquement dédié à
cela mais peut-être insisté sur un
dispositif qui est nouveau qui est le
portail de signalement des violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui est portée à
la fois par la police nationale et par
la gendarmerie nationale
nous l'avons inauguré il ya quelques
mois de cela je crois avec nicole
belloubet christophe castaner et laurent
nunez et cette plate forme de
signalement qui est disponible sur
service public.fr elle mobilise deux
unités de police et de gendarmerie 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 elle se
trouve physiquement à rennes en ille et
vilaine et à guyancourt en ile de france
et elles répondent aux signalements
des victimes ou des témoins de violences
sexistes et sexuelles et j'ai pu
constater à la fois sur place dans le
cadre de ce portail de signalement mais
aussi lors de déplacements nord
récemment et ailleurs à quel point ce
portail de signalements travaille en
lien avec les polices et les
gendarmeries pour faire en sorte que
cela débouche sur de véritables plainte
physique et sur ensuite une prise en
charge et une judiciarisation et donc ce
portail de signalement des violences
sexistes et sexuelles il représente un
coût d'installation et un coût de mise
en oeuvre de 1,7 million pour 2010 9 454
1000 euros pour l'installation des deux
plateformes et 1 33 million d'euros
précisément de masse salariale nous
avons pas assez le détail de l'ensemble
des autres crédits qu'ils s'agissent à
des référents préfectoraux du fraternité
appréhension la délinquance affiliés à
l'uss contre les violences des logement
et de l'hébergement je vous passe les
détails parce que je pense que ce serait
sinon un peu long mais je voudrais
rappeler que les actions du gouvernement
à cet égard se sont mobilisés et dans le
cadre de cette plateforme nous avons
3835 chat très précisément qui ont été
traités par les policiers et les
gendarmes et qui ont débouché sur 1230 7
signalements direct auprès des forces de
l'ordre pour pour enquête
ça veut dire qu'il ya des conversations
avec les policiers les gendarmes
parfois ça nécessite plusieurs
conversations pour arriver à une plainte
est ce que cette plainte soit qualifiée
est ensuite transmise au parquet cette
plateforme elle vient en soutien à
l'action du 39 19 vous avez avec cette
plateforme un signalement aux forces de
l'ordre directement et avec le 39 19
vous avez un accompagnement en 2018
l'état a déjà financé trois postes
supplémentaires des coûts tente pour le
39 19
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que le 39 19 puisse prendre 100 % des
appels qui lui sont passés et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons l'année
dernière augmenter de 3 postes
supplémentaires pour qu' aucun appel ne
sonne dans le vide et un million six
cent soixante cinq mille euros ont été
accordés aux 39 19
en 2019 et en plus de cette somme le 39
19 a reçu une augmentation
supplémentaire qui a été calculé par la
fédération nationale solide et rate
solidarité femmes elles mêmes
qui gère le 39 19 pour prendre le
surcroît d'appels lie à la campagne du
grenelle des violences conjugales
surtout leur avons demandé d'estimer le
surcroît d'appels et le besoin en
écoutant t elle nous ont fourni ce
besoin et nous l'avons rempli en terme
d'augmentation de subventions par
ailleurs le 39 19 a reçu le label grande
cause nationale le premier ministre a
attribué ce label qui a permis d'obtenir
des diffusions gracieuse de campagne de
communication et d'information
directement de l'association dans les
radios et dans les télévisions publiques
et en plus de cela il ya eu la grande
campagne de communication dans le cadre
du grenelle des violences conjugales
pour améliorer la connaissance du 39 19
je voudrais préciser qu'en plus de cela
le gouvernement met en place des
contrats locaux contre les violences qui
sont des partenariats signés avec les
acteurs à même de détecter ou d'être
informé de violences sexistes ou
sexuelles police-justice associations
élus locaux aux travailleurs sociaux qui
autour des préfets se réunissent pour
mieux faire circuler l'information mieux
partager les alertes et à terme mieux
protéger les femmes en pouvant
intervenir de la sorte les moyens qui
ont été affectés aux associations ont
donc augmenté avec une pression
d'abonnement significative en 2019 au 39
nous avons ajouté également un appel à
projet d'un million d'euros qui
s'appelle le fond catherine contre les
féminicides pourquoi parce qu on a
calculé que dans votre entourage vous
connaissez à peu près autant de victimes
de violences conjugales que de femmes
qui s'appelle catherine c'est ça peut
sembler gadget mais c'est une une appel
à la réflexion pour chacune et chacun et
que tout le monde puisse s'interroger
sur la quantité de ce phénomène des
violences conjugales et ce fonds d'un
million d'euros il est spécifiquement
dédié aux petites associations locales
c'est-à-dire à celles qui sont parfois
en dehors du scope puisque 1300
associations sont financées en tout par
l'état sur ce sujet là et donc ça nous
permet d'avoir un complément pour
soutenir des projets locaux et à ce
sujet je voudrais vous dire mesdames les
sénatrices et monsieur sénateurs que je
fais évidemment votre disposition pour
que vous puissiez dans les théâtres
toute association locale qui aurait
besoin d'appeler notre attention par
votre intermédiaire parce que vous
auriez le sentiment que cette
association locale n'a pas assez de
financements pouvoir mener à bien ses
projets et que nous pourrions compléter
par l'intermédiaire de ce fonds un
certain nombre de propositions
voilà pour ce qui concerne le grenelle
des violences conjugales mais bien
évidemment je répondrai à toutes les
questions que vous voudrez me poser à
cet égard sur le sujet de l'émancipation
économique des femmes
je voudrais rappeler très brièvement le
travail qui a été mené par ma collègue
muriel pénicaud dans le cas de la loi
sur de la loi à venir pro sur la
transparence dans l'égalité des salaires
et la poursuite de démarches de la
labellisation égalité faire mention de
la question des pensions alimentaires et
ce qu'il répond madame la présidente à
la question que vous me posiez sur le
plfss puisque les évolutions du
dispositif de prélèvement des pensions
alimentaires seront intégrés au plfss
est donc portée par la mise des
solidarités et de la santé et donc ça
sera un volet important en ce qui
concerne l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes ça fait partie aussi de
l'émancipation économique des femmes
dans le cadre de cette loi qui a été
annoncé par le président de la
république au g7 la loi pour
l'émancipation économique des femmes
nous avons confié à chiara corazza qui
est la présidente du women's forum
une mission sur la place des femmes dans
le numérique
parce qu'on s'aperçoit et plusieurs
études ont bien démontré je ne leur
documente pas ici que l'orientation des
jeunes filles et des filles vers les
filières de sciences technologie macs
numérique etc abaisse considérablement
d'année en année dans tous les pays
d'europe et il nous pensons que c'est un
un enjeu très fort à la fois d'égalité
femmes hommes mais aussi d'innovations
de performance de développement
économique pour le pays et donc yara
coradia qui a beaucoup travaillé dessus
avec beaucoup de partenaires notamment
d'entreprises d'associations et de
réseaux de femmes va nous remettre très
prochainement à bruno le maire cédric
haut et moi même des propositions pour
rendre attractives ces filières
vis-à-vis des femmes
j'ai par ailleurs également confié une
mission au conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes qui est désormais
présidée par brigitte grésy que vous
connaissez sur la question des quotas
le hcr est chargé d'étudier la
faisabilité
et modalités de réhaussement des quotas
avec plusieurs scénarios qui sont sur la
table et qui sont étudiées notamment la
possibilité de réhausser jusqu'à 50% les
quotas de femmes au sein des conseils
d'administration des conseils de
surveillance des entreprises mais aussi
la possibilité ou d'examiner la
faisabilité pour étendre ce dispositif à
toutes les autres instances de
gouvernance des entreprises et/ou
également d'expertisé des modalités de
réhaussement de tout quotas existants on
peut toucher la très largement à la fois
les quotas dans l'entreprise mais aussi
les quotas dans la fonction publique et
je pense bien sûr aux quotas de primes
aux nominations des hauts fonctionnaires
et à la loi sauvadet mais il ya
également un certain nombre de
personnalités qui porte dans le débat
public la volonté de mettre en place des
quotas dans les écoles scientifiques
écoles d'ingénieurs et c'est déjà ça
fait partie également du débat dans le
cadre de cette loi pour l'émancipation
économique des femmes
nous allons travailler à l'application
de la loi sur l'égalité salariale à
l'ensemble du secteur public puisque
l'état est pour l'instant loin d'être
exemplaire en matière d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes à cet égard il
nous pensons que l'état comme
investisseur peut avoir un rôle à jouer
notamment en donnant à bpi france un
mandat de vérifier de soutenir la
diversité de genres dans les entreprises
dans lesquelles elle investit et de
veiller surtout à ce que les faire
l'entrepreneur ne soit pas discriminer
l'état investisseurs donc l etat
actionnaire qui peut également donner
mandat à la bourse des participations de
l'état de fixer et de mesurer des
objectifs qui soient claires et
déterminées sur la place des femmes au
sein des organes de direction des
sociétés de son portefeuille
de la même manière qu actuellement elle
suit les rémunérations nous sommes en
train de travailler avec bruno le maire
et avec les secrétaires d'état concernés
par ce sujet par ailleurs nous pensons
que dans cette fois nous pourrons
discuter avec les parlementaires de la
mise en place d'un budget genre et dj
under budget singh de l'état il ya trois
expérimentations qui ont été lancés par
l'état depuis 2010 est appliquée au
ministère des sports de la culture et de
l'agriculture a rappelé que ce n'est pas
une innovation particulière ya déjà
beaucoup de pays dont le maroc par
exemple qui ont mis en place des budgets
genre et et c'est une revendication du
conseil consultatif pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes du g7
nous sommes par ailleurs en train de
discuter un certain nombre de mesures
bancaires puisque entre le droit
bancaire et l'arrêt
était il ya parfois une divergence est
donc avec la fédération bancaire
française nous menons ce travail de
concertation avec bruno le maire mais
également la transposition dans la loi
des dispositions de la convention
d'istanbul notamment surtout la question
des violences économiques qui n'existe
pas en tant que tel actuellement dans la
loi française avec la france c'est bien
évidemment engagé à transposer par
ailleurs nous pensons pouvoir créer un
fonds pour les femmes dans l'innovation
en marge de cette loi et des mesures de
formation spécifique pour accompagner la
reprise d'activité des femmes après un
arrêt travail des hommes aussi également
due majoritairement ce sont les femmes
qui s'arrêtent de travailler pour
s'occuper des enfants
nous sommes en train de travailler
également sur mesure liée à la parité
notamment sur la hausse des pénalités
pour les partis politiques qui ne
respectent pas la parité lors des
constitutions modiste d'élections nous
proposons une maison au débat public la
multiplication par cinq de ces pénalités
pas réellement des amendes qu'on appelle
à mende par abus de langage qui sont des
retenues pour qu'elle soit réellement
dissuasif c'est une mesure que nous
sommes en train de travailler en
interministériel et pour laquelle nous
allons évidemment consulter les
différents partis politiques afin
d'avoir leur sentiment sur ce sujet là
et je serai très preneuse de vos
différents retours vous qui êtes les
représentantes et les représentants des
territoires sur vos avis par rapport à
cette mesure
la question des quotas des jeunes filles
je les ai évoqué tout à l'heure et je
veux passer pour terminer je ne sais pas
combien de temps il me reste ou si j'ai
dépassé le temps qui m'est imparti à la
question de la diplomatie fait mise
puisque vous savez que la france porte
depuis deux ans sous l'impulsion du
président et de jean yves le drian une
diplomatie féministes qui se traduit par
différentes actions notamment
financièrement
l'augmentation considérable des crédits
en soutien à l'initiative sidi saïd pour
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
partout dans le monde de l'engagement de
6 millions d'euros pour le fonds ou krug
et que j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais
aussi la présidence française du g7 qui
a donné pour la première fois lieu à un
partenariat de biarritz pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république avec un engagement de tous
les pays du g7 incluant les états unis
d'amérique a implémenté dans l'année qui
vient une loi proposé par le conseil
consultatif pour l'égalité femmes hommes
dans le cadre du g7 et enfin l'accueil
du forum génération égalité sous l'égide
d'onu-femmes une des priorités de la
france au cours de la présidence du g7
du conseil des ministres et du conseil
de l'europe en 2009 ça a donc été faire
avancer l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes en général et
particulièrement la lutte contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
nous avons lancé au forum mondial pour
la démocratie à strasbourg en novembre
2018 et avons réitéré l'engagement de la
france à la csw en mars dernier et lors
de la dernière conférence organisée par
le grès viaud en mai et dans ce cadre la
france a encouragé l'ensemble des états
du conseil de l'europe qui n'ont pas
encore fait à signer et à ratifier la
convention d'istanbul et nous avons
invité à la fois dans cette instance est
également en bilatéral ensemble des
états non membres du conseil de l'europe
à y adhérer avec une perspective claire
qui est celle de l'universalisation du
texte qui est porté bien sûr par le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian également dans le cas de
la diplomatie féministes de la france
nous avons présenté un plan de lutte
contre l'excision à la fois en france
mais aussi partout dans le monde avec un
plan lutte contre ces mutilations
présentait donc en le 21 juin dernier en
partenariat avec différentes
organisations comme le gams excision
parlons-en
le conseil national des gynécologues
obstétriciens français équilibre
population et la maison des femmes chez
qui nous étions les enjeux sont
d'enrichir l'état des connaissances
d'établir un état des lieux
ces mutilations sexuelles féminines de
mieux sensibiliser
prévenir améliorer la santé de ces
femmes et faire de la france un pays
exemplaire face aux mutilations
sexuelles et d'accompagner de travailler
en coopération avec les autres pays qui
souhaitent s'engager dans cette démarche
notamment le burkina faso le tchad où
j'ai pu me rendre avec le président la
république
dernièrement la présidence française du
g7 a pas a permis je crois de marquer un
engagement fort dans le cas de la
diplomatie féministes de la france
puisque à l'occasion cette présidence
française les chefs d'état ont adopté la
déclaration j'évoquais du partenariat de
biarritz ont soutenu le fonds
international pour les survivantes
violences sexuelles liées à un conflit
ainsi que pour l'éducation et la
formation des filles et des femmes et
dans le cadre de cette présidence
française la france a donné un élan à
l'initiative afin world qui a été lancé
par la banque africaine de développement
en 2020 23% des femmes africaines ont
accès au crédit ça veut dire que les
trois quarts des femmes ont aucun nom
qu'il était urgent à notre sens d'agir
pour faire en sorte que les femmes
notamment africaines où les femmes en
france y entreprennent les femmes
françaises pardon qu entreprennent en
afrique puisse être mieux soutenues et
donc la france est engagée à hauteur de
135 millions d'euros sur l'initiative va
falloir et le g7 a mobilisé en tout
environ 251 millions de dollars pour
financer ce mécanisme qui est à cheval
entre le microcrédit et l'aide au
développement qui permettra de garantir
les financements des femmes en afrique
puisqu'ils sont plus difficiles à
garantir pour les questions notamment
législatives que vous connaissez dans le
cadre du g7 le conseil consultatif pour
l'égalité femmes hommes qui est donc co
présidée par nadia mourad que vous
connaissez et de nîmes au courrier que
vous connaissez également est composé
d'environ 35 activistes et experts de
l'égalité femmes hommes
ce conseil a identifié 80 lois
favorables à l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes avec un une sorte de
benchmark des meilleures lois mondiales
et les plus efficaces dans quatre
secteurs que ce conseil a déterminé
violence autonomisation économique
éducation et santé discrimination et ce
travail s'est appuyé sur l'expertisé des
membres du conseil
avec le soutien de l'onu femmes le
conseil a remise ce recueil de lois
ainsi qu'un appel à l'action des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement et dans cet
appel le conseil demande aux dirigeants
de s'engager à adopter à mettre en
oeuvre des cas de législatives
progressistes pour l'égalité femmes
hommes
en s'inspirant de ses recommandations le
président de la république a par
ailleurs demandé à ce conseil
consultatif pour l'égalité femmes hommes
de perdurer même après la présidence
française du g7
afin de vérifier si les engagements pris
par les différents états sont
véritablement tenu et si chacun dans
l'année à venir a véritablement
implémenter une oie enfin dans le cadre
de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies le mois dernier le président de la
république a lancé un appel en disant
que nous devons donner un statut
juridique au féminicide partout dans le
monde
à la tribune des nations unies la france
a élargi la coalition du partenariat de
biarritz conclu dans le cadre du g7
de nombreux pays se sont d'ores et déjà
engagés je pourrais citer l'espagne a su
l irlande l'afrique du sud et quelques
autres et le président de la république
a appelé tous les pays à s'engager dans
le forum génération égalité le forum
génération égalité il a lieu à paris en
2020 soit 25 ans après la conférence
mondiale de pékin qui avait lieu donc en
1995 la france organise sous l'égide
d'onu femmes et en lien avec le mexique
ce forum génération égalité du 7 au 10
juillet prochains à paris j'espère
toutes et tous vous y voir tous les
acteurs contribuant à la promotion des
droits des femmes et à l'égalité femmes
hommes partout dans le monde seront
annoncés on attend environ 5000
participants plusieurs centaines de ng
du monde entier environ 50 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement des personnalités
mondiales engagé pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes qui dans ce cas
pourront marquer sous l'impulsion
d'onu-femmes monde un engagement partagé
pour faire une génération qui
connaissent l'égalité parfaite entre les
femmes et les hommes partout dans le
monde
les conditions de participation pour que
vous les ayez en tête c'est un
engagement au niveau national à
rejoindre le partenariat biarritz donc à
modifier le cadre légal ou une politique
publique en faveur des droits des femmes
est un engagement au moins pris au
niveau international c'est à dire au
moins participer à une des coalitions
qui sont prévus dans le cadre de ce
forum et je crois que ce forum
génération égalité il sera un succès si
tout le monde s'engage
de la même manière
n'hésitez pas à vous adresser à nous
pour que nous puissions avancer ensemble
dans cette grande mobilisation
immobilisations pardon national qui
permettra à chacune et à chacun de
porter des messages
féministe et pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes partout dans le
monde alors que vous le savez les droits
des femmes sont plus que jamais menacés
à cet égard moi je crois que 2020 va
être une année importante pour la
diplomatie féministe la prochaine csw en
mars va être l'occasion de porter nos
engagements collectifs au nom de la
france pris depuis deux ans et demi dans
le cadre de cette diplomatie féministe
mais aussi de porter les engagements qui
j'en suis sûr sortiront du grenelle des
violences conjugales c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons pouvoir faire en sorte qu'une
grande délégation représentant la france
puisse y participer et je suis donc
naturellement la disposition de toutes
les sénatrices et de tous les sénateurs
qui voudraient travailler dans le cadre
de cette csw préparer une délégation
française
à cet égard voilà j'espère ne pas avoir
été trop longue l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes vous le savez c'est
une priorité de ce gouvernement en tout
cas c'est la mienne je sais que c'est la
vôtre aussi et je vous remercie d'être
présent dans ce cadre et c'est pour ça
que vous êtes là et donc je fais
évidemment à votre écoute pour répondre
si je le peux et sujet les éléments qui
permettent de répondre à vos questions
et sinon les trouver par la suite avec
nous puissions avancer ensemble sur tout
sujet sur lequel vous voudriez porter
mon attention répondre à vos questions
sur les actions transverses du
gouvernement et peut-être construire
ensemble d'autres mesures sur différents
sujets
merci madame la ministre alors les jours
merci tous ces propos toutes ces
annonces qui ont été faites fin d'après
midi
j'ai un certain nombre de paroles qui
sont prises de paroles qui sont des
questions qui sont demandés moi je veux
juste faire trois remarques et peut être
à la fois en même temps trois questions
et après je prendrai part série 2 de 3 2
2 3 sénateurs sénatrice pour qu'on
puisse avancer dans les temps
comment réussissez-vous à passer de 200
appels à 600 appels avec trois postes
en plus des coûts tente donc ça c'est ma
première question
j'ai eu un rendez vous
aujourd'hui avec des représentants des
gynécologues médicaux
on le sait un certain nombre j'avais
posé différentes questions
les gynécologues médicaux font souvent
grand défaut dans certains départements
qui ne connaît qui n'en n'ont pas donc
aujourd'hui il ya le cnp qui a rassemblé
gynécologues médicaux et gynécologues
obstétriciens
or on connaît le rôle du cnt à la fois
de porter la formation de gérer les
budgets de formation et d'être
l'interlocuteur privilégié du
gouvernement donc est il possible
il semblerait que ce soit possible
auprès de la ministre de la santé de
revenir à 2cm p
et vous avez fait appel à nos
territoires nous sommes tous et toutes
sénateurs de territoire moi lorsque je
regarde le territoire de la vendée je
vais faire d'abord un constat sur les
moyens des associations
le cidff vendée est logé dans des locaux
qui sont absolument pas digne de la
mission c'est à dire que la personne qui
assure le conseil juridique part en
courant le soir puisqu'elle allait à
l'arrière d'une tour d'immeuble et ne se
sont pas du tout rassuré en quittant ses
locaux au sous-sol et l'association sos
femmes vendée accueille des femmes et
des enfants dans des conditions
relativement précaire chez précaire en
exagérant forçant le trait mais malgré
tout lorsqu'on accueille des enfants et
des femmes qui ont été victimes de
violences les conditions dans lesquelles
on doit les accueillir doivent être
totalement parfaite
c'est à dire pour qu'ils puissent déjà
trouvé un refuge et un début de
reconstruction et la dernière
intervention sadate juste de vendredi
vous avez parlé du plan excision et je
salue la présence de nos deux collègues
sénatrice maryvonne blondin et martin
décidera qu'il ne manquerons pas de
revenir peut-être sur le travail
qu'elles ont menées cette année lors de
l'année précédente parlementaire j'ai
reçu vendredi à ma permanence de la
roche-sur-yon une jeune femme du tchad
khadija c'est ça khadija qui a été
débouté
une demande d'asile excisée qui a subi
de nombreuses violences dans son pays
qui demandent le droit d'asile qui n'a
pas eu la possibilité de s'exprimer son
dossier a été un dossier administratif
refusé elles risquent l'expulsion le 24
octobre prochain
avez vous dans votre plan excision à
gérer des mesures particulières
accordez-vous une attention particulière
à toutes ces femmes qui sont excisées
dans le monde et qui risquent leur vie
si elles retournent dans leur pays
d'origine
cette jeune femme est partie elle a
quitté en laissant ses enfants sa mère
qui a gardé ses enfants est partie dans
un pays voisin puisque les enfants
certes servait de de diray d'armes
contre la mer donc que faites vous aussi
pour toutes ces femmes qui demandent
l'asile dans notre pays après des
violences et des excitants d excision
pardon donc je vais tout de suite 3
trois premières interventions et je vais
le passer la parole à martha de sidrac
si vous le permettez non par séquences
de trois comme ça ça nous permet
d'avancer un peu plus rapidement
puisqu'il aura probablement des sujets
qui vont se recoupent et martin décidera
merci madame la présidente
merci madame la ministre d'être parmi
nous aujourd'hui et en introduction je
voudrais évidemment vous rassurer nous
partageons pleinement les objectifs que
vous nous présentez
peut-être avons-nous quelques désaccords
sur les moyens et sur les outils que
voilà que vous souhaitez vous déployez
donc moi je vais revenir pour ne pas
être trop longue sur un certain nombre
de chiffres que vous avez partagé avec
nous et vous nous avez annoncé que vous
nous remettez riez à la fin de la séance
un document donc
on le regardera avec beaucoup
d'attention bien évidemment toutefois
donc je reviens
je reviens au lancement du grenelle des
violences et à ce moment là il a été
annoncé vous l'avez rappelé 1 millions
d'euros pour le fonds catherine est
également 5 millions d'euros qui
seraient débloqués pour de l'hébergement
pour 1000 places d'hébergement pour des
femmes qui subissent des violences
conjugales
il y un rapport en fait du cee qui est
paru en 2018 dans lequel il disait qu'en
réalité le montant qu'ils qui était
consacré aux violences faites aux femmes
étaient de l'ordre de 80 millions
d'euros à peu près il parlait de 78
millions d'euros
vous même à l'occasion d'un plateau sur
bfm ou rmc avec monsieur bourdin vous
avez dit que vous faisiez tas en fait de
530 millions d'euros qui était consacrée
évidemment à ces sujets très grave
votre budget est autour de 30 millions
d'euros
tout à l'heure vous avez partagé un
certain nombre de chiffres
malheureusement je ne laissais pas
notées notamment le chiffre que vous
avez évoquées pour le ministère des
affaires étrangères le ministère des
affaires intérieures
donc est ce que ma première question est
donc celle là comment comptez vous
identifier très clairement dans le cadre
du budget les postes contre toutes ces
violences en fait ministère par
ministère et comment vous allez décliner
en fait dans votre plan d'action global
pour que nous soyons concrets dans les
territoires que nous puissions relayé ce
que vous
ce que vous nous communiquez riez et
comment le faire intégrer dans le budget
véritablement de chaque ministère
comment est-ce qu'on s'y retrouve en
réalité puisque aujourd'hui on en entend
des chiffres qui sont toujours en
contradiction les uns avec les autres et
en fait on s'y perd un tout petit peu
dans tout dans tout cela donc j'aimerais
savoir un tout petit peu plus
madame la présidente j'ai une deuxième
question si vous permettez j'essaierai
d'être bref c'est au tour du numéro 39
on me dit qu'en réalité il n'est pas
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 ce qui m'étonne
terriblement voilà donc ça c'est quelque
chose sur lequel je souhaiterais que
vous nous rassurer aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est inadmissible
aujourd'hui vu l'état vous même vous
nous avez rappelé les les terribles
chiffre autour de ces violences certes
il ya des sujets de moyens mais je crois
que quand on a la volonté
il faut pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout donc
j'aimerais que vous me rase riez et
dernier sujet nous travaillons dans les
yvelines moi je suis dit sénatrice des
yvelines autour de l'hébergement avec
monsieur le préfet avec les référentes
autour des violences conjugales
et là encore je suis désolé tout revient
aux moyens mais nous n'avons très
clairement pas les moyens donc moi je
vais lancer une mobilisation des élus
mais là encore vous voyez ce seront les
communes qui vont être au premier plan
or dans la mesure où vous même vous
annoncer cette ambition gouvernementale
qui a été annoncé dès l'élection du
président aujourd'hui très clairement le
compte n'y est pas donc je voudrais
concrètement que vous nous rassure y est
et que vous nous dégager des mots et des
moyens merci merci chers collègues si
vous le permettez on prend une troisième
question c'est ma notre collègue martine
filleul
si madame la présidente madame la
ministre merci de se prêter à cet
exercice des questions réponses qui
n'est pas toujours facile alors j'ai
noté dans votre propos mais cela n'est
pas nouveau des mots comme écoute
portail de signalements places
d'hébergement 39,19 aide aux victimes
tout votre action et même le débat
public porte sur
l'aspect répression et sur l'aspect
accompagnement des femmes déjà victimes
de violences mais pour ma part je pense
que il faut mettre fin à ce cycle
infernal des violences conjugales
véritablement les éradiquer et donc
travailler sur un volet prévention
or les unes et les autres peuvent
témoigner je pense que sur leur
territoire les associations qui oeuvrent
au plus près des filles des femmes qui
peuvent être des proies plus faciles
pour les violences en particulier dans
les quartiers voient leur subvention
diminuée je pense par exemple à la
prévention spécialisée dans les
quartiers elles voient leur subvention
diminuée que pensez vous avez vous un
volet prévention que vous tenez secret
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez
ensuite je voulais vous interroger sur
le droit à liv et j'ai l'exercice de ce
droit en france est de plus en plus
contrarié les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes
entre 2007 et 2017
hors fusions d'établissements 27 centres
sont ouverts et 70 ont fermé en france
métropolitaine avec une perte de 43
centres sur un total de 600 24 des
femmes aujourd'hui doivent faire parfois
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres pour
pouvoir avoir accès à ce droit que
compte faire le gouvernement pour que la
loi soit véritablement respecter
ensuite vous parlez de l'allongement du
congé de paternité en autriche récemment
je crois début septembre
ce le congé de paternité a été porté à
un mois avec une allocation de 700 euros
par mois pour un site est effectivement
les pères à prendre ce congé de
paternité
et puis également
je ne me trompe pas mais c'est les
espagnols également qu'ils ont allonger
le congé de paternité à l'image de ce
qui se fait dans les pays nordiques les
plus progressistes dans le domaine est
ce que vous pensez mettre en oeuvre un
congé paternité de cette nature en
france fin de cette longueur en france
et enfin votre propos sur la diplomatie
des femmes
mam m'a également porté à vous porter à
vous poser une question puisque vous
parler d'innovation de création
d'entreprise de start up en afrique tout
ça est très bien de nan mais pardon de
les encourager d'une manière générale la
création d'entreprise l'innovation
je trouve que c'est très très bien mais
néanmoins j'ai en tête des chiffres qui
montrent que le taux de scolarisation
des femmes en afrique baisse dans
certains pays au pire et au mieux
stagnent est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que la priorité dans dans ce domaine et
en afrique eux s'imposent devrait
s'imposer à nous en matière de
diplomatie
merci chers collègues je vous laisse
répondre de madame la ministre
beaucoup merci d'abord d'avoir écouté
mon propos liminaires et merci pour vos
questions madame la présidente je me
suis je n'ai sans doute pas donné assez
de détails sur le 39 19 mai il y a eu en
fait dans un premier temps trois
nouvelles les écoutantes sur l'année
précédente et ensuite de nouveau de
nouvelles écoutante pour absorber le
surcroît d'appels au 30 à visa donc en
fait il ya eu deux fois de recrutement
de trois écoutante vous dire si c'est
suffisant ou pas actuellement je ne le
peux pas mais nous avons justement prévu
de faire un bilan d'étape
avec le 39 19 pour voir si c'est
suffisant ou pas il est évident que
étant donné que nous avons diffusé très
largement ce numéro téléphone c'est
notre priorité absolue est bien
évidemment s'il ya besoin d'avoir encore
de nouvelles écoutante bien évidemment
nous mettrons les moyens pour qu'il y
ait encore de nouvelles écoutante aux 39
19 incluant évidemment les formations de
ces écoutante parce qu'en gros en
moyenne il ya trois quatre mois de
formation pour pouvoir ensuite être
écoutante au 30/09/10
je me permets de répondre en même temps
à l'autre question qui portait sur le 39
non il n'est pas ouvert 24 heures sur 24
à l'heure actuelle il n'a pas été c'est
un numéro qui existe depuis maintenant
quelques années mais c'est un objectif
du gouvernement nous voulons faire en
sorte qu'à terme ils soient ouverts 24
heures sur 24
donc nous sommes en train de travailler
avec l'association qui le portent avec
plusieurs objectifs d'abord le premier
c'est de rappeler à chaque fois que nous
pouvons dans le débat public que ce
n'est pas un numéro d'urgence parce que
je pense que le fait de communiquer sur
ce numéro est évidemment très positif et
permet de le faire connaître et je veux
pas qu'il y ait de confusion et je
voudrais rappeler que c'est un numéro
d'écouté et d'accompagnement et qui
n'est pas un numéro d'urgence et
d'intervention pour ça c'est la police
et la gendarmerie et autres petites
difficultés de de l'état de
l'administration de la loi c'est qu'on
doit passer par un marché public si on
veut ouvrir ce numéro sur un volume qui
soit de vingt quatre heures sur vingt
quatre et sept jours sur sept
donc ça nous demande en fait un petit
peu de travail avec l'association pour
construire les objectifs et construire
qui seraient les objectifs d'une
ouverture vingt quatre heures sur vingt
quatre
un peu de travail y compris de
changement de locaux puisque les locaux
actuels ne sont pas adaptés sur ce sujet
là et puis un petit travail législatif
en termes de marchés publics nous sommes
en train de travailler avec
l'administration chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes donc
c'est pour vous réponds clairement en ce
moment il n'est pas ouvert 24 heures sur
nous voulons qu'ils soient ouverts 24
heures sur 24 ça nécessite un travail un
peu faim et nous sommes en train de
mener ce travail
j'espère vous avoir répondu sur le 39 19
sur la question des locaux et des
associations en vendée à madame la
présidente sur les cidff ses 4,6
millions d'euros qui sont engagés au
total sur les antennes locales en plus
de l'antenne nationale et donc les
crédits du cidff comme vous le savez ils
sont fournis un par l'état en direct
avec les représentants dans les
préfectures qui fournissent un certain
nombre de subventions indirectement par
l'état via les subventions accordées au
national au cidff qui ensuite peu selon
certains cas rebasculer au niveau local
mais aussi par les collectivités région
ville département toutes celles qui
souhaitent abonder ces montants là je ne
sais pas qui appartiennent locaux
actuels du
df f1 vendée met volontiers si vous
pouvez me faire passer un dossier que
nous puissions regarder plus en détails
et y compris bien sûr sur sos femmes et
c'est valable pour tout autre
association qui seraient en difficulté
en matière de locaux en ce qui concerne
l'asile pour les femmes liées à la
question des mutilations génitales
normalement c'est prévu dans les textes
et daf normalement une femme qui est
menacée de mutilations génitales dans
son pays même pas forcément qui a été
victime mais même qui est menacée de
mutilation génitale elle doit pouvoir
trouver refuge en france donc je ne
connais pas le cas particulier de la
femme dont vous faites état qui vient du
tchad mais normalement il est il est
bien évident que à la connaissance
d'après les connaissances dont je
dispose et empiriquement elle aurait dû
pouvoir être accueillis et je ne peux
pas vous dire ne connaissant pas son
dossier
pourquoi elle n'a pas été mais mais
c'est effectivement souhaitable qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient accueillis sur la
question du budget en tant que ce soit
je me trouvais à vous de jouer la
sénatrice
j'entends que ce soit extrêmement
complexe et c'est tout l'objet du dpt en
fait l'objet du dpt c'est de faire
remonter justement de chaque ministère
les crédits engagés qui seront engagés
donc en prévisionnel en futur ou au
conditionnel sur l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
et c'est un exercice assez difficile
même pour les ministères eux-mêmes parce
que par exemple en ce qui concerne
l'hébergement vous pouvez engager un
prévisionnel de crédit mais
l'hébergement l'offre dépend de la
demande et donc ça dépendra de la
demande de l'année qui vient donc c'est
un peu subtil c'est la même chose pour
l'évaluation sur aller bracelet anti
rapprochement
on évalue on imagine qu'il y aura tant
de condamnation et que donc on estime à
à telle somme
et c'est ce qui fait que le dpt et cet
exercice un peu compliqué mais vous
aurez dès demain l'ensemble des chiffres
émanant des ministères eux mêmes
j'entends qu'il ya différents chiffres
sur le budget qui circulent et je sais
qu'on est dans une période où personne
n'a fois en personne et où le
complotisme prévaut sur tout mais il me
semble que les documents qui viennent de
la direction du budget de l'état sont
quand même fiable et peuvent faire foi
en matière de chiffres pour le budget et
donc le dpt en faisant
alors je ne vous le fais pas dire
comment dire
alors c'est l'objet c'est l'objet de ce
que je vais vous distribuez on a fait un
petit exercice en essayant d'être le
plus sincère et transparent possible idc
banon met plein la vue 8,0 à regarder a
plein d'argent
l'idée c'est d'essayer justement de
transcrire les chiffres du dpt qui sont
pas toujours très intelligible dans des
graphiques et les camemberts et des
chiffres extraits avec des exemples qui
permettent de se repérer un petit peu
dans des p&t donc moi je ne suis pas
ministre du budget je fais avec
l'exercice contre 1 du tableur excel et
du programme les uns après les autres
mais en tout cas ceux des p t il et
public à partir de demain
nous on a fait le travail depuis
quelques semaines avec les différentes
directions administration pour sortir et
traduire quelque chose si vous avez
besoin de précisions évidemment à la
fois le ministre gérald darmanin et moi
même nous sommes à votre disposition
s'il ya des choses qui vous paraisse pas
clair t'as cohérente ne pas correspondre
ou qui vous interroge sur tel ou tel
engagement du jetair vraiment n'hésitez
pas une fois qu'il sera sorti et que
vous en aurez pris connaissance si on
peut vous éclairer sur ce sujet où ils
compris si vous trouvez qu'il ya des
crédits qui sont insuffisamment élevé
sur telle ou telle volée on est
évidemment à votre disposition mais
c'est justement l'objet du dpt est
l'objet du powerpoint qu'on a essayé de
faire à partir de céder péter sur le 39
19 je vous ai répondu sur la question de
la prévention oui c'est alors je ne st
pas secret un plan de prévention
il ya un groupe de travail justement qui
va avancer sur la prévention
il ya une proposition qui a été faite
pendant grenet des violences conjugales
que moi je le soutiens personnellement
que je trouve très bonne de mettre en
place un brevet dans les écoles de lutte
contre les violences qui permettent à
chaque enfant comme on l'est sur la
sécurité routière comme on le fut sur
l'écologie d'être véritablement
sensibilise et une proposition qui a été
faite par une association
moi je la soutiens il ya un groupe de
travail qui va se réunir et avancer sur
ce sujet mais j'ai envie de vous dire
aussi que tout est lié et en fait il ya
plein de moments où on fait de la
prévention sans avoir l'air de faire de
la prévention
quand on lutte contre les stéréotypes
sexistes qui sont diffusées à la
télévision
quand je m'insurge contre des blagues
sur le viol qui sont diffusées à des
heures de grande écoute c'est pas juste
pour le plaisir de faire un signalement
au csa c'est parce que derrière je pense
aux jeunes filles aux petites filles que
mal de mes enfants qui regardent et
qu'ils avaient en fait c'est marrant
d'être violent
c'est normal d'être tabassé c'est normal
d'être forcée à avoir des relations
sexuelles etc etc
je crois que ça ça fait partie de la
prévention aussi ce volet de lutte
contre les stéréotypes c'est la même
chose quand on soutient les femmes dans
le sport soutenir les femmes championne
dans le sport ses souvenirs
une représentation des femmes qui soient
pas forcément là comme objet de désir ou
de non désir mais comme des femmes
puissantes musclé qui gagne qui
remportent des tournois etc
je pense que ça participe aussi de la
prévention et j'entends ce que vous
dites aussi madame la sénatrice sur le
fait qu on est peut-être trop sur le
volet prise en charge des victimes
et je vous rejoins parce que c'est un
constat qui est factuel que vous faites
je partage ce constat il est dû à
l'histoire comme vous le savez de la
lutte pour les droits des femmes et
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles qui a été très longtemps très
longtemps il ya une ou deux générations
un impensé des politiques publiques qui
a été fait par les associations qui se
débrouillaient pour accompagner les
femmes et sans l'avoir mis en place une
stratégie sur ce sujet les stratégies de
politiques publiques elles ont une
génération une génération et demi dont
quatre sont en fait très récente
il ya encore des angles morts à mon sens
dans ses politiques publiques par
exemple la prise en charge des auteurs
de violences j'étais à arras la semaine
dernière j'ai pu visiter l'un des seuls
centres en france qui prend en charge
les auteurs de violences conjugales qui
a été co créé notamment par luc frémiot
avec je partage pas la vision du
gouvernement mais qu'il a fait quelque
chose de positif puisque ça a démontré
qu'on est passé en termes de récidive de
60 et quelques % à 13 % et j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec des hommes auteurs de
violences conjugales qui ont été
accompagnés et il m'est apparu je ne
suis pas travailler au social mais il
m'est apparu avec un regard extérieur
qu'effectivement ça pouvait porter ses
fruits
et en plus j'ai pu découvrir à cette
occasion que ça n'était pas si cher que
ça je devrais pas le dire comme ça mais
en fait je pense que ce n'est pas si
cher que ça un centre de prise en charge
des auteurs de violences conjugales
comme celui d'arras
il coûte en un peu moins de cent mille
euros par an avec douze hommes qui
peuvent être hébergées et accompagner et
en tout à l'allier c'est entre 30 et 40
hommes qui sont accompagnés donc en fait
ça veut dire que très clairement si on
trouve des collectivités des régions des
partenaires qui sont disposés à mettre
une partie du financement
nous on peut assez facilement passer
facilement mais on peut en tout cas
c'est du domaine du faisait à dégager
des financements pour accompagner ces
hommes et faire de la prévention
luttons contre la récidive je pense que
ça ça va être vraiment un ongle tournant
du grenelle des violences conjugales sur
les subventions je voudrais rappeler ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous et
toutes les subventions sont en baisse
moi les supp quand les subventions
baissent par dont l'odeur comme ça mais
il ya plusieurs possibilités nous en
moyenne il ya plus 21 3 % de subventions
en moyenne c'est à dire qu'il ya des
hausses qui sont bien plus forte
excision parlons-en je crois c'est x 4
quelque chose comme ça le mouvement du
nid contre la prostitution 39 19
le collectif féministe contre le viol
etc il peut y avoir des subventions qui
baisse à des associations
il ya des raisons en général que ce soit
l'état que ce soit les régions que ce
soit les villes cantons bs une
subvention à une association
il ya une raison derrière et nous notre
raison elle est pas budgétaire à chaque
fois que c'est pas parce qu'on dit il ya
plus d'argent on baisse la subvention tu
peux toujours aller trouver de l'argent
ailleurs je n'ai eu de cesse d'abonder
mon budget avec matignon avec les autres
ministères etc
quand une subvention belle c'est que
souvent la déléguée régionale ou la
déléguée départementale aux droits des
femmes de l'état qui est en préfecture a
estimé que le dossier n'était pas solide
et que l'activité en face n'étaient pas
suffisantes pour maintenir ou augmenter
la subvention
il peut arriver qu'il y ait des erreurs
des trous dans la raquette et que ce
soit pas le cas et dans ces cas là là
aussi je suis très preneuse des dossiers
des associations en question si vous
estimez qu'il ya une baisse qui est pour
vous injustifiée et que l'état devrait
remettre des crédits sur ces
associations on peut évidemment en
discuter et donc si vous avez les
mentions de ces associations on peut
voir à l'issue entendre sur la question
de l'ivg et j'ai c'est pas de mon
ressort directement mais quand même
puisqu'il s'agit de droits des femmes et
des qu'elle était droit des femmes
je voudrais rappeler quelque chose qu'on
sait tout et tous ici mais rappelez
quand même la difficulté à attirer 2
façon générale dans le métier de
gynécologue a attiré dans le métier de
gynécologues qui exercent des
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
et a attiré dans le métier gynécologue
qui exercent des ivg dans certaines
zones et moi même je suis élu rang
sarthe et en fait on est une zone de
désert médical et c'est extrêmement long
et extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
accès à l ivg ya des femmes qui habitent
en sarre qui vont à paris pour avoir un
accès à libérer parce qu'on est dans une
de désert médical et je ne dis pas qu'à
paris ce soit facile rapide et c deja
mais le constat que vous faites je le
partage il ma collègue la mise de la
santé est pleinement engagée elle a
publié récemment notamment une carte qui
permet via une cartographie d'avoir
accès justement à l'ensemble des
professionnels qui pratiquent les ivg
pour ne pas faire plusieurs gynécologue
et se retrouver dans des délais qui sont
parfois extrêmement difficile je
voudrais préciser sur le congé paternité
qu'il y a une mission qui a été confiée
par le premier ministre à l'igas
justement sur la manière d'améliorer
congé paternité avec plusieurs scénarios
qui nous ont été proposés soit
d'amélioration de la rémunération du
congé paternité soit d'allongement de la
durée du congé paternité pour vous
répondre madame la sénatrice mort à
titre personnel je pense que c'est le
sens de l'histoire d'allonger le congé
paternité
la france ne va pas rester avec un congé
paternité à 11 jours tout compris donc
on va allonger le congé paternité mais
je ne peux pas prendre d'engagement au
nom du gouvernement en vous disant dans
l'année qui arrive le gouvernement va
proposer d'allonger le congé paternité
mais après les parlementaires ont aussi
vocation à pouvoir proposer un certain
nombre de lois et notamment celle ci sur
l'allongement du congé paternité la
question étant quel scénario on retient
est ce qu'on retient un allongement de
la durée à une amélioration du
financement et comment on se lance cet
allongement de la durée qu'il n'est pas
qu'il n'y ait pas un petit sujet mais
qui est un sujet auquel on peut faire
face puisque nous avons justement dans
cette mission à l'igas dont c'est à dire
c'est une démarche que nous initions et
que par ailleurs comme nous sommes
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale de la
femme rurale
je me permets de rappeler que nous avons
collectivement toutes et tous améliorer
le congé maternité des femmes
agricultrices et je pense que c'était un
pas important pour faire en sorte
qu'elles puissent être sécurisés dans
cette partie de leur vie je voudrais
préciser madame assez triste que je n'ai
pas parlé de start up
je sais qu'on a la réputation d'être
focalisé sur les start-up je n'ai pas
prononcé ce mot là néanmoins je crois
que la place des femmes dans
l'innovation elle et elle est importante
elle est fondamentale et je la firme le
fait de pouvoir créer des entreprises
aussi moi je suis très attaché à faire
en sorte de ne pas défendre uniquement
une vision des femmes victimes de
violences sexistes et sexuelles même si
c'est extrêmement difficile parce qu'à
chaque fois je me dis je vais parler de
quelque chose de positif pour les femmes
on
rattrapé par la réalité des faits qui
font qu'elle les femmes sont entravés
par ce que la société les créer des
conditions pour qu'elle soit victime de
quoi que ce soit mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai salué aussi l'attribution du prix
nobel à une femme française pour
l'économie et c'est avec mon saoul
tonneau la capacité des femmes à créer
des entreprises mais vous avez tout à
fait raison sur l'éducation
je n'ai pas mentionné parce que c'est un
engagement qui est porté politiquement
par jean yves le drian jean michel
blanquer armé d'un islam en je le
soutiens à 100% la france mais 66
millions d'euros sur l'accès à
l'éducation des petites filles c'est
partout dans le monde
c'est pas dans le monde en termes de
co-développement et je n'ai plus le
chiffre en tête et donc je vais pas vous
dire de bêtises mais il me semble que
nous avons augmenté nous avons enfin
nous avons multiplié en tout cas la
contribution de la france à l'accès à
l'éducation des filles dans le cas des
programmes de l'onu de façon
considérable je vous donnais le chiffre
de l'augmentation si je peux le chercher
dans l'intervalle qui nous ait laissé le
fait de passer un petit peu après ça
permet de raccourcir aussi au niveau des
questions qu'on lui posait puisqu'il ya
déjà eus il ya déjà eu des réponses donc
moi je ne vais pas réitéré sur le 39 19
peut-être simplement pour savoir à quel
horizon contenu du travail que vous êtes
en train de faire vous pensez que
effectivement ce numéro pourra être en
mis en oeuvre 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7 avec quand même le fait que
effectivement les écoutantes les
écoutant son boivent être formé et que
c'est aussi pour avoir visité
c'est une grosse pression qui repose qui
repose sur l donc voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un horizon par
rapport à ceux 39 19
la deuxième deuxième question que je
voudrais vous poser concerne l'audit que
vous avez lancée au niveau du grenelle
du grenelle le guide de ses 400
commissariat donc moi je suis assez
dubitative comme beaucoup d'associations
sur cet audit dame ministre puisque en
fait on n'est pas toujours d'accord
entre associations féministes entre
féminisme et je dois dire qu'ici il ya
une chose que l'on que l'on partage
c'est l'état des lieux des choses qui ne
vont pas dans les commissariats
notamment et des choses qui vont parce
que tous heureusement il ya des choses
qui qui avancent donc l'état des lieux
on le connaît ce qui ne va pas on le
connaît et je veux dire qu'on est même y
compris plutôt d'accord sur les
propositions alternatives et ça passe
beaucoup par la formation par un temps
de formation par une qualité de
formation même si là encore chez obligé
d'aller d'aller vite il ya des choses
qui auraient qui ont été faites sur ces
questions là il ya des évolutions me
reste encore beaucoup à faire et il ya
des grandes inégalités entre territoires
mais là encore on est quand même assez
bien placé pour avoir nous aussi un état
des lieux et vous vous le transmettre
donc quand je suis dubitative parce que
je me demande finalement à quoi va être
utile
cet audit alors que finalement ce qu'on
aimerait avoir ce qu'on aimerait
entendre c'est effectivement un plan de
formation notamment
évidemment pour les pour les policiers
et puis également en lien avec le
personnel de santé
et là je rejoins une question monti qui
est importante à mes yeux c'est la
question justement de de la formation
des médecins généralistes etc et de la
façon dont on va repérer et orienter les
femmes qui sont victimes de violence et
notamment je pense à un questionnaire
qui a été qui a été recommandé élaboré
par plusieurs experts dont muriel
salmona mépacq pas qu'elle est c'est un
questionnaire unique en fait
d'évaluation du risque de féminicide et
c'est une technique a été utilisée au
québec et dont les résultats vis
finalement semble assez probant donc
je voudrais savoir ce qu'ils permettent
un accompagnement de la victime une
prise en charge et je voudrais savoir
parce qu'à ma connaissance je n'ai pas
vu je n'ai pas lu je n'ai pas entendu
que c'était une piste que vous alliez
suivre et comment comment vous alliez
faire et du coup c'est un lien avec les
unités de prise en charge globale qui
devrait être installé
normalement au moins dans chaque
département pour l'instant il y en a que
onze qui ont été qui ont été annoncées
j'ai posé une question à la ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn pour quand même
savoir un petit peu comment ces unités
vont être mises en place que je suis
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales et je dois dire que
devant les restrictions budgétaires qui
pèsent sur les hôpitaux je ne vois pas
très bien comment on va pouvoir
installer ces unités qui sont absolument
indispensables pour les victimes aussi
pour les familles avec quels moyens en
termes financiers mais en terme en
termes humains donc voilà si vous
pouviez nous dire la troisième question
c'est sur l'hébergement
alors là j'aimerais avoir quelques
quelques précisions aussi vous l'avais
un peu abordée mais franchement les
chiffres dont nous disposons sont
extrêmement contradictoires et je suis
un peu étonné quand on nous annonce la
création de 1000 places en 2020 étonnée
parce qu'au début du quinquennat il ya
eu une politique de réduction de 57
millions d'euros de subventions contre
les centres d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale d'ici 2022 et se
sont quand même 20 millions qui a été
retiré en 2018 donc comment tenir alors
la promesse de création de ces mille
places d'hébergement d'urgence d'urgence
pardon et des deux logements temporaires
avec donc ces restrictions et qui plus
est comme le montre le document d'
analyse de la banque des territoires
donc voilà sénatrices et sénateurs on y
est sensible
une place donc d'hébergement peut
difficilement se financer avec moins de
dix sept mille euros donc si on fait le
calcul par rapport aux chiffres que vous
avez donné ça explose pardonnez moi
cette expression familière les compteurs
et pour ne pas être plus longue
je veux ajouter je veux ajouter un
élément je suis intervenu en faveur des
femmes de chambre de l'hôtel ibis aux
batignolles
on a eu un petit échange au niveau de
twitter ça m'a un peu étonné mais
pourquoi pas et en tout cas j'ai pris la
balle au bond puisque vous m'avez
proposait finalement de pouvoir
travailler avec vous donc je suis tout à
fait moi je veux bien venir partager des
concertations et c'est simplement
effectivement j'ai besoin d'une
invitation est en tout cas par rapport à
cette problématique des femmes de
chambre de l'hôtel ibis
je souhaiterais qu'effectivement vous
puissiez examiner la question avec nous
puissions être reçu avec vous et
accompagner des femmes de chambre parce
que c'est elle qui connaissent bien
cette problématique merci permettez moi
de vous exprimer ma surprise lorsque
quelques jours après avoir passé le
rapport enfin le projet de résolution au
sénat en mars dernier sur justement les
mutilations sexuelles féminines
nous apprenions j'apprenais la sortie de
votre plan excision et dans ce plan il
n'était pas fait mention du travail qui
avait été fait par la délégation aux
droits des femmes et aucune référence à
à cela et ce travail de la délégation
aux droits des femmes était aussi une
suite de travail que j'avais fait en
2013 au conseil de l'europe dont je suis
membre et avec marlene rupprecht nous
avions déjà fait un travail sur le sujet
et rien n'avait été
mentionné dans dans ce plan aucune
référence et aucun appel
enfin je sais pas si la présidente de la
délégation n'a reçu mais nous n'en avons
pas rue alors ça c'était ce point de
surprise par lequel je voulais commencer
néanmoins tout à l'heure vous avez
évoqué également cette diplomatie
féminine on va dire j'ai eu le plaisir
et l'honneur d'être appelé pour défendre
justement la position de la france dans
le cadre de ce g7 à riga en lituanie
pour faire en sorte de les informer sur
la convention d'istanbul parce que la
lituanie après avoir failli ratifié et
bien a fait marche arrière et c'est
vraiment difficile dans ces pays de
réussir à faire en sorte que la
convention d'istanbul est là la mention
orientation sexuelle qui apparaît bien
dans la convention des droits de l'homme
qu'ils ont signés parce qu'ils sont
membres du conseil de l'europe
et bien ça ne ça ne passe pas lorsqu'il
s'agit de la convention d'istanbul donc
il va falloir remettre un peu ce travail
là encore et toujours sur le métier vous
dire également que le jeu vient de faire
passer est là j'étais tout seul je viens
de faire passer est adopté un rapport
sur les violences gynécologiques et
obstétricales début du mois d'octobre
dernier qui a été adoptée évidemment il
ya eu une abstention je crois à vérifier
mais a été adopté j'aimerais savoir
exactement ce que nous vous l'avez vous
avez demandé au hce de faire un rapport
là dessus donc ça m'a aidé dans mes 47
pays évidemment à travailler et
j'aimerais savoir si une proposition de
résolution quelque chose serait possible
en france parce que l'objectif c'est de
faire adopter des rapports de ce type au
conseil de l'europe
mais ensuite de pouvoir les faire
appliquer et adapter le droit français
donc j'aimerais savoir si ça peut être
également envisagé et la rapporteure
générale des nations unies madame
simonovic que j'ai rencontrée elle
faisait également un rapport sur cette
thématique et qu'elle a présenté le 4
octobre
moi j'ai présenté mon rapport le 3
octobre le 4 octobre elle le présenter à
la salle à l'assemblée générale des
nations unies à genève
donc on pourrait à partir de tous à
faire un travail je crois assez assez
intéressant vous avez mentionné les 25
ans est ce que vous allez mettre en
place après la conférence de pékin c'est
quelque chose qui est très très attendu
et le travail avec le gremio j'espère
que la france je suis ça avec beaucoup
d'attention et j'espère que la france
coopèrent et prend en compte les
remarques ou les observations qui
peuvent être faits de même je rejoins
mes collègues présidents précédentes
parce que l'hébergement reste toujours
une solution difficile et si on n'arrive
pas à pouvoir développer et surtout
apporter des financements
je crois qu'on aura beaucoup de mal à à
pouvoir mettre en place ces c
hébergement spécifique et tout à l'heure
vous évoquez une partie des financements
du ministère des affaires étrangères
pour accompagner par exemple
l'association du docteur mogwai et j'ai
cru comprendre que dans l'aide au
développement d'une manière générale il
y avait une baisse et que
est-ce qu'on en prend un peu encore de
cette baisse pour m vers ces actions là
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
difficile et agoras justice évidemment
qu'il y ait cette une association qui
travaille en lien avec les procureurs et
et les présidents de tg je crois sont
dans des des contraintes budgétaires
terrible et n'arrivent pas à apporter
tout le soutien continu
après la après la condamnation très
souvent de leurs de leur mari dont ils
ont besoin des financiers voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire bien de commencer
par la question de des délais madame la
sénatrice sur l'ouverture de 39 19
mon vise c'est un objectif ce n'est pas
un engagement c'est un objectif que je
partage avec vous sur l'ouverture 24
heures sur 24 sept jours sur sept du 39
on dise 2021 parce que c'est ce qui nous
semble faisable et nabeul en termes de
délai pour préparer à la fois le travail
de fond le changement éventuel de locos
le la fédération nationale solidarité
femmes remportait ce marché public mais
aussi la mise en oeuvre justement
juridique de la question du marché
public vous avez tout à fait raison de
souligner que c'est une grosse pression
pour les écoutantes je partage je me
suis rendu je crois à quatre ou cinq
fois depuis que j'ai été nommé au 39 19
longuement à chaque fois avec les
écoutantes à la fois ce qui fonde le pré
accueil
c'est à dire de l'orientation est qu une
pression très forte part qu'elles
doivent en peu de phrases qualifié
exactement la nature des violences
et vous savez toutes et tous ici que
quand une femme appelle elle dit pas
j'ai été victime de tels types de
violence dès la reprise et des amis
qu'il faut parler avec elle c'est une
charge psychologique très forte et on le
sait puisque il ya des élus vous n'êtes
que des élus autour de cette table on
sait très bien que quand on gère tous
les jours des appels échos
d ailleurs que ce soit des appels des
mails des dossiers moi j'en vois des
centaines par jour de lettres avec des
photos des descriptions précises des
gens qui nous arrêtent dans la rue pour
nous en parler des permanences d'élus
quand on a dix personnes à la chaîne qui
viennent nous montrer ce qu'elles ont
vécu et c'est extrêmement fort et donc
on s'assure de faire en sorte que les
écoutantes soit bien accompagné soit
bien prise en charge sont des très
grands professionnels qui sont qui sont
très engagées sur ces sujets mais vous
avez raison d'insister sur la pression
qui est la leur et sur la formation et
de l'accompagnement qui doit donc être
celui de l'état auprès d'elle sur la
question de l'audit sur les
commissariats effectivement j'ai enfin
je pense que vous parle la réflexion que
vous faites elle est partagée par
beaucoup d'associations qui la formule
aussi dans les mêmes termes en disant en
gros j'espère ne pas travestir votre
avancée mais en gros on sait ce qui va
pas ça fait des années qu'on dise qu'il
va pas dans l'accueil dans les
commissariats pourquoi refaire un audit
par dessus et je comprends vraiment ce
point de vue pour avoir moi même publié
des travaux dans lesquelles j'ai compilé
toutes les phrases incroyable entendu
dans les commissariats quand on va
déposer des plaintes pour des violences
sexistes et sexuelles je vois très bien
à quoi vous faites référence mais je
crois qu'on a besoin d'avoir un constat
partagé et qu'on ne peut pas rester dans
le d'un côté des associations des
victimes qui disent l'accueil en
commissariat ça va pas et de leur côté
les forces de l'ordre qui nous disent
ils accueillent en commissariat ça va
très bien un moment on a besoin de
pouvoir objectiver les choses de voir ce
qui n'a pas aller il ya parfois une
différence entre
ce qui est une différence de perception
entre les uns et les autres et on a
besoin justement avec cet audit dans les
400 commissariat de pouvoir avoir un
constat qui soient partagées et qu'ils
soient incontestables de part et d'autre
mais ce constat
cet audit il s'accompagne bien
évidemment d'une grille d'évaluation du
danger le premier ministre edouard
philippe l'a annoncé
mais ça a été assez peu repris au
détriment enfin au profit plus
exactement de l'audit
mais c'est une grille d'évaluation du
danger qu'ils aient travaillé avec l'ami
prof
elisabeth moins nombreux que vous
connaissez qui est secrétaire général de
la mission un terminal de protection des
femmes qui a fédéré plusieurs
d'association avec elle pour travailler
sur sa grille d'évaluation
je saurais pas vous dire si muriel
salmona ya été associés ou pas en tant
que tel mais en tout cas je sais qu'être
elle travaille depuis des années avec
les commissariats pour faire en sorte
justement que sa grille d'évaluation joe
danger permettent de façon factuelle de
pouvoir savoir s'il ya un danger de mort
imminent ou pas et de mettre en oeuvre
justement sa grille d'évaluation pour
une action qui soit immédiate et qu'on
ne laisse pas repartir les femmes sans
solution et c'est également le l'état
d'esprit qui a guidé la haute autorité
de santé dans la construction son
questionnement de son de son
questionnaire pardon justement pour
procéder aux questionnements
systématique des soignants qui est un
engagement qui avaient été portées par
le président la république quand il a
lancé la grande cause du quinquennat
pour faire en sorte qu'à chaque
rendez-vous médical cette question soit
posée
c'est un peu une arlésienne qui a été
travaillé par les associations par des
soignants est porté par différents
gouvernements j'ai regardé dans tous les
plans interministériel précédant à
chaque fois tous les gouvernements dit
notre objectif c'est d'aller vers le
questionnement systématique ça jamais
été vraiment mis en oeuvre mais là je
crois qu'il ya une mobilisation vraiment
toute la société et notamment de la
haute autorité de santé qui va permettre
je l'espère d'avancer vers cette mise en
oeuvre est encore une fois sa demande
vous avez coup la demande et sans le sou
ligné du temps et donc des moyens parce
que ce questionnement systématique on
sait très bien qu'en ce sont des cases à
cocher
quel est votre pointure des joues plus
tu l âge avez vous été victime de
violence oui non personne ne coche wii
ou très peu de femmes même quand on a
vraiment été victime de violences et
donc ça nécessite un travail
approfondie avec les soignants je sais
que la mise de la santé il est très
attaché également sur la question des
unités de soins psychotraumatiques que
vous répondre quantitativement et vous
dire simplement qu'il ya dix unités de
soins psychotraumatiques ont été
ouvertes partout en france à l'exception
je crois de une région je crois qu'il ya
un il ya une zone de la france qui n'est
pas couverte je sais plus laquelle la de
mémoire la nouvelle aquitaine et qui
doit être donc dans le prochaine appel
en priorité pour faire en sorte que tout
le territoire soit couvert ont la visite
on a visité l'une de ses unités
récemment avec adrien taquet et je crois
que cette prise en charge de soins
psychotraumatiques or une fois elle est
assez récente
le le fait simplement de comprendre que
quand on a été victimes de violences
sexistes et sexuelles au monde
développent des psycho traumatisme c'est
quand même récent il ya dix ans on
pensait que le psycho trauma c'était les
vétérans de la guerre du vietnam et pas
les femmes qui avaient été victimes de
violences sexistes ou sexuelles dont
accompagne cette évolution de la société
autant que faire se peut sur
l'hébergement
je rejoins là encore votre constat sur
le fait que c'est par voie basse simple
de sortir des chiffres qui mettent enfin
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient corroborer
de part et d'autre je vais essayer de
vous apporter des réponses sur la base
des informations dont je dispose qui
proviennent des administrations
concernées sur les chiffres en espérance
à répondre à votre question souligné
qu'il y a donc 5715 places d'hébergement
qu'ils sont exclusivement dédiés aux
femmes victimes de violence sur l'année
2019 et qui a mille créations en plus
prévu sur 2020 et qui sont financés ces
1000 places avec les cinq millions
d'euros supplémentaires annoncées par le
premier ministre honnêtement j'avais
fait le calcul du coût de revient par
place là je pense qu'on s'y retrouve
oui voilà sachant qu'elle et les autres
places qui étaient déjà créé par
ailleurs mais on a un tableau de
répartition en région par région si vous
souhaitez on peut le vous le faire
parvenir à l'issue de l'audition ch ans
que ce sont les données que nous on a pu
faire remonter
différentes administrations très
honnêtement non sans mal pour être
transparents avec vous et c'est
d'ailleurs une des missions que nous
avons donné aux groupes de travail sur
l'hébergement c'est de rendre
intelligible
les données sur l'hébergement d'urgence
au cours du grenelle des violences
conjugales à matignon le ministre du
logement et marie cervetti que vous
connaissez qu'il ya une femme un toit
ont eu un échange sur ce sujet et elle
même a convenu que leurs échanges
pouvait être difficile d'accès pour des
profanes en la matière et donc je crois
que pour que chacun puisse véritablement
à la fois les engagements du
gouvernement mais surtout très important
de voir comment ces places sont ventilés
et comment elles sont attribuées qu'on
puisse vraiment avoir un référentiel
commun d appellation commune et un
schéma de financement qui soit fléchés
de façon beaucoup plus clair que ça ne
l'est à l'heure actuelle c'est 90
millions en 2020 c'est ça sur
l'hébergement d'urgence pour les
logements qui sont mes dispositions pour
les femmes et je voudrais insister juste
sur le dispositif visage parce que je
crois que c'est quand même une petite
révolution le fait que l'état va
maintenant se porter garant pour que les
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
puisse au delà des hébergements
d'urgence
louer un appartement avec une garantie
visage ce qui s'appelait loca-pass quand
on était jeune mais je pense que c'est
extrêmement important
très rapidement sur la question des
femmes de chambre ce que je veux pas
monopoliser sur un échanges
interpersonnels en fait madame la
sénatrice moi même j'ai été surpris donc
sans surprise mutuellement de voir que
vous aviez sur twitter lancé un appel à
venir manifester sous mes fenêtres je
trouvais ça un peu hétérodoxe vous avez
dit on se retrouve sous les fenêtres de
marlène schiappa smiley fait du bruit
etc
je trouvais ça un peu hétérodoxes en
tant que parlementaire de venir
encourager à venir sous mes fenêtres
vous n'aviez jamais sollicité
directement sur la question des femmes
de chambre c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis permis de m'étonner de la
méthode auprès de vous j'ai vu votre
courrier qui a fait tout le circuit du
bureau des courriers qui est arrivé sur
mon bureau
hier est donc bien évidemment je serais
ravi qu'on puisse se rencontrer en
aparté et oui mais c'est le on reçoit
près 400 à 500 courriers par jour donc
le temps qu'il soit traité par le bureau
des courriers vous connaissez le
principe
hélas voilà mais honnêtement très
souvent ça va plus
mais donc tout ça pour dire que sur les
femmes de chambre
évidemment moi je me suis rendu à l'ibis
à batignolles comme vous savez je
rencontrais notamment les déléguées
syndicales mais surtout les femmes de
chambre qui travaillent jeté avec le
député de la circonscription stanislas
guérini je rentrais la direction aussi
mais surtout j'ai confié au csp une
mission qui sera présenté dans les
contours seront présentés bientôt je
sais plus quoi exactement
mais le dans les deux mois le csp va
mener une mission de consultation
notamment avec les différents
partenaires sociaux pour arriver à des
propositions qui soient très concrètes
j'ai lu votre courrier j'ai vu que la
demande s'était la fin de la
sous-traitance et ça honnêtement moi
comme j'ai déjà dit aux femmes de
chambre il m'appartient pas en tant que
gouvernement d'arbitrer sur un modèle
économique légales telles que la sous
traitance
néanmoins sur les conditions de travail
les pauses la protection est bien
évidemment le fait absolument scandaleux
40 viols aient pu se produire sur un
lieu de travail auprès des femmes de
chambre en créant des conditions
d'insécurité dans l'exercice de leur
travail de toutes les autres femmes de
chambre sont une chose absolument
scandaleuse sur lesquels il ya urgence à
travailler donc je vais répondre à votre
courrier j'espère qu'il vous parviendra
dans des plus rapide que celui que j'ai
mis pour le traiter et qu'on pourra
avancer là dessus ensemble sur l'action
du plan excision madame la sénatrice je
prends note de ceux dont vous me faites
par ces jeunes-là compris vous avez mené
un travail important notamment depuis
2013 avec vos collègues sur la question
de l'excision et on n'a pas fait
référence et on ne s'est pas basée sur
votre travail c'est une malle politesse
de ma part donc je m'en excuse platement
auprès de vous et de vos collègues en
fête bat pour m'excuser mais pour donner
contexte on était vraiment la tête dans
le guidon et on a vraiment eu à coeur
d'associer toutes les associations et
vous avez raison on a commis l'impair et
le sénat y avait déjà travaillé avant
nous et on a commis l'impair de ne pas
faire appel à vous et de ne pas nous
baser sur votre travail
on sera je serai vigilant de la
prochaine fois faire en sorte de
vraiment associer tout le monde on fera
un point d'étape sur le plan et de
saison et peut-être que ça peut être
l'occasion ensemble de partager le
travail que vous avez menées peut-être
au ministère peut être pourriez vous le
rappeler madame la ministre
excusez-moi de vous interrompre
peut-être pourriez-vous le rappeler le
fait que vous n'ayez que vous ayez
oublié le sénat dans le cadre de plus du
plan et 6
ça nous ferait plaisir le rappeler le
rappeler parce que vous avez beaucoup
communiquer mais en revanche le travail
du sénat et de la délégation c'est ce
que n'a pas du tout été valorisés et je
le regrette beaucoup
j'entends c'est ce que je viens de
répondre à votre cas après ça paraît un
peu impromptue si là je fais un
communiqué de presse pour dire j'ai
oublié sénat d'emploi excision il ya eu
huit mois j'en suis désolé néanmoins je
vous propose justement un rattrapage et
je vous propose que dans le secrétariat
d'état on fasse un point d'étape est que
ce soit vous qui puissiez présenter ce
point d'étape en valorisant et en
mettant en avant le travail que le sénat
a accompli sur la question de l'excision
et ça peut être peut-être une manière
c'est à la chine et ensemble évidemment
voir si ça vaut combien de cette manière
mais ce serait peut-être une manière
justement positif de valoriser cela est
à cette occasion je pourrais rappeler
que je déplore moi même de ne pas avoir
associé le sénat ce premier plan et que
vous êtes
nous allons je vais tenter de réparer
cette omission
à cette occasion bien sûr c'est à vous
convient de la sorte pour améliorer plan
absolument si ça vous convainc
évidemment mais peut-être la bonne
nouvelle c'est que votre travail à
infuser je sais que c'est terrible quand
on use et ça moi je déteste quand on dit
vous avez gagné la bataille culturelle
quand on a repris mes idées mais cela
dit c'est vrai dire le travail que vous
avez mené à infuser parce que on ne
s'est pas réveillé au gouvernement en
disant tiens au fait c'est à l'excision
mais c'est parce qu'il ya eu une demande
forte et sa demande je suis sûr qu'elle
a infusé par le travail évidemment qui a
été menée depuis des années sur la
question de la convention de d'istanbul
vous avez tout à fait raison et on a un
travail à mener pour lutter contre un
certain nombre de fausses d'information
dans certains pays et notamment je me
permets de dire dans certains pays de
l'est qui vise à dénaturer la convention
d'istanbul à faire croire que c'est une
convention qui attaquent la famille qui
promeut le gens qui prônent le
changement sexe des enfants etc et à
tout ce qu'on entend habituellement sur
ces sujets moi je m'attèle dans tous les
goûts toutes les instances
multilatérales à faire en sorte de
défendre cela dans le cas de notre
campagne de promotion et de ratification
de la convention d'istanbul ça nous
montre à quel point le travail de
diplomatie femise des parlementaires est
extrêmement important également puisque
la diplomatie féministe elle n'est pas
porté uniquement par le gouvernement
allait porter aussi au nom de la france
par les parlementaires et par les ong
absolument tout à fait en ce qui
concerne le grill
on attend nous les recommandations du
griot est bien évidemment la france est
engagée à les suivre
donc c'est grey vieux nous dit que la
législation française n'est pas à la
hauteur zi de la convention d'istanbul
je pense qu'elle nous dira notamment sur
ce sujet des violences économiques sur
la question du viol il ya débat puisque
son d'istanbul prévoit que la définition
du viol soit un rapport sexuel avec
pénétration sans consentement
la loi française avec menace surprise
violence on verra s'il considère que
c'est le cas ou pas on l'attend en tout
cas et je ne peux que vous féliciter sur
le rapport sur les violences
gynécologiques et obstétricales
je serai moi même et à genève le mois
prochain je pense que ce sera l'occasion
également de absolument tout à fait avec
plaisir dans ces cas là et de voir
comment avant sur ce sujet juge rappelle
qu'il ya deux ans quand j'avais annoncé
vouloir travailler sur les violences
gynécologiques et obstétricales je
venais d'être nommé j'avais à peu près
une semaine et demi d'ancienneté et j'ai
dû faire face à un à des appels à la
démission massif pour avoir osé dire que
oui moi aussi il m'a écrit récemment
voilà sur pour une rencontre est de
nouveau sur ce sujet mais je veux
rappeler quand même non pas pour me
plaindre mais pour dire quand même il ya
une avancée dans le débat public
à l'époque joseph quand on vient d'être
nommé depuis deux semaines est content
juste je voudrais que les femmes
puissent accoucher dans le bien-être
sans qu'on pratique des actes médicaux
sans leur agit surtout d actifs point du
mari etc et autres voilà je pense que
c'est ça nous montre à quel point on a
pu avancer sur ce sujet donc en tout cas
c'est quelque chose de positif
voilà pour cette audition de marlène
schiappa vous avez pu suivre sur notre
antenne vous pouvez retrouvez tous les
articles de la rédaction de public sénat
sur notre site publicsenat.fr
notamment cet article qui revient dans
les détails sur l'édition de marlène
schiappa avec ce titre harcèlement de
rue 894 infraction constatée depuis la
mise en oeuvre de la loi annonce
malaysia parent c'est l'une des
informations à retenir de cette audition
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très bonne sur des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
mais